welcome back to cbs this morning
pharmacies like cvs and walgreens will
help administer the coronavirus vaccine
first
to long-term care residents and staff
and eventually
to all of us in the general public now
walmart and sam's club are also
preparing their pharmacies for the big
roll
out their first doses left pfizer's
michigan plant yesterday
i just love looking at the trucks
rolling arrow barnard is at a cvs in
troy michigan that's outside detroit
with more on the story errol good
morning to you so when will nursing
homes
start receiving the actual vaccine
yeah good morning gail we all love
seeing this get going well cvs
and walgreens have made an agreement
with the federal government to pick up
the baton now
and distribute this vaccine to high
priority groups across the country
but this race is happening so quickly
there is some confusion about exactly
when
these most vulnerable groups will get
their first doses of the vaccine and
nursing home staff and residents
are among that group vaccinations can't
happen a moment too soon not a day too
soon
dr richard pfeiffer is the head of
genesis one of the largest u.s
nursing home operators genesis
healthcare genesis is working with cvs
to get nursing home residents and staff
at its more than 300 facilities
nationwide
vaccinated tell us how you are
coordinating with cvs to get
vaccines to all of your people cbs's job
is supply chain they're going to make
sure that the vaccine gets to where it
needs to go
they're going to bring in the
vaccinators and the technicians so we're
shipping
2.9 million on face the nation sunday
health and human services secretary alex
azar said
as soon as the vaccines are received
this week
they can be administered but cbs news
obtained two documents from operation
warp speed
the federal government's vaccine program
they make it clear
vaccines can only be administered after
december 21st
a full week from today former fda
commissioner dr scott gottlieb suggested
sunday
that's likely because operation warp
speed didn't obtain consent
in advance from nursing home residents
or their families to be vaccinated
it's a very costly delay there's 50 000
new infections in nursing homes every
week right now probably more than that
more than 76 000 residents in long-term
care facilities have died from covert 19
and nearly 1200 staff members we trust
that the vaccine supplies
are getting out extraordinarily quickly
while some might see
the use of cbs and walgreens to roll
this out as really
fast and efficient you're cautioning
that it could actually lead to bumps
down the road
i guarantee you it will lead to bumps
down the road
dr michael wasserman is immediate past
president of the california association
of long-term care medicine
the federal government sort of handing
the
distribution of the vaccine for nursing
homes to
cbs and walgreens was not really well
thought out
we're anticipating a lot of chaos
in the process last week l.a county
pulled out of the federal vaccine
program
instructing nursing facilities to take
on their own vaccine administration
a move wasserman encouraged this really
needs to be
coordinated at the facility level
now a senior administration official
explains to us that the delay was in
part because they couldn't request
some healthcare workers and staff may
receive the vaccine
before next week on monday and if you
are wondering when you may be able to
get access to this vaccine keep in mind
this first wave of doses
is just for frontline workers the rest
of us anthony are not likely to have
access to this for a few months maybe
even the spring
or summer all right errol thank you